[MUSIC PLAYING]
DINO CHIESA: Dino here.
If you've watched the other
videos in this series,
you're well on your
way to becoming
familiar with Apigee
Edge, and you're
seeing how you can
begin to exploit
the capabilities of Apigee to
further your digital business.
You'll be able to continue using
Apigee Edge for the duration
of your evaluation.
Here are some suggestions
for helping you move forward.
First, if you'd like to share
this learning experience
with your teammates
or colleagues,
you can invite other people to
your Apigee Edge organization.
You can work as a
team of collaborators,
building your API
program together.
You can explore
further by joining us
for a virtual API jam.
These are live webcast events.
Check the events
page for details.
If you want to further
your education with a more
thorough course of
training, please
visit academy.apigee.com,
where we have
extensive online courseware.
There you can get started on
the path to certification.
In case you would
like to describe
the capabilities of Apigee
Edge to your colleagues,
we've prepared some materials
you can use for that purpose.
Finally, if you'd like to have
a conversation with an Apigee
technical or sales
representative
to discuss solution scenarios,
architectures, capabilities
in more detail,
our sales team will
be more than happy to help.
I hope you've enjoyed
this video series.
If you have any
feedback, we'd love
to hear from you on
the Apigee community.
Thank you, and as
always, keep it digital.
[MUSIC PLAYING]